[Music]
I'm Patrick Stewart and I'm going to
read you some one-star reviews of iconic
locations all over the world starting
near home the Statue of Liberty if I'm
going to take a boat out into the middle
of the water
I want this lady to do something beyond
just stand there like can it be a ride
or something
Stonehenge dated it could do with a good
clean and some fresh paint
sadly past its best gateway arch so if I
bend the piece of metal and stick it in
the ground I can charge a bunch of money
for suckers to go in it the only art
worth visiting is the golden one that
sells hamburgers Mount Rushmore loved
the monument hated the location South
Dakota really the Hoover Dam more like
the Hoover Dam this is disappointing
correct me if I'm wrong but anyone can
build a wall to contain water it's
called a bathtub Natural History Museum
I just don't like stuffed animals I find
them very creepy go somewhere else
the Eiffel Tower do you know who loved
the Eiffel Tower Hitler
you
you